now here's where it gets interesting
imagine you're out on site somewhere in
the middle of nowhere typical remote
australia you're walking through the
long grass and a nostalgic sound place
all of a sudden your world flashes and a
wild snake appears before you even have
time to pull out your pokeball and
choose pikachu unfortunately that snake
has bitten you poisoned you and escaped
you're down to the count nowhere to go
nowhere to run no reception more
importantly and you're looking at death
right in the eye so what happens in this
situation well with any other mobile
phone you're most likely going to die
unfortunately that is a sad reality
however with the iphone 14 now for the
first time ever you have satellite
emergency communication basically
allowing you to use any satellite in the
sky to get an sos message out this
feature could truly be the difference
between a phone that saves your life and
a phone that just sits in your pocket if
you want to see the full video and all
things architecture related make sure
you hit that subscribe button